welcome trainers
thanks for joining us today for a
preview of the upcoming game pokemon
legends arceus releasing january 28th
exclusively on the nintendo switch
system today we wanted to give you a
first look at some new gameplay let's
begin your adventure is set in the
expansive history region
in an age long ago when it was rare for
people in pokemon to live in close
harmony and time isui will come to be
called the sinnoh region
mount coronet rises from the center of
the hisou region surrounded on all sides
by areas with distinct environments
each area is rich in natural features
and plays host to different pokemon
ecosystems
one such area is the obsidian field lens
which you can see the trainer exploring
here the area is filled with pokemon
that call meadows and forests their home
each area in hisui has loads to discover
and you should make sure to collect a
variety of different raw materials as
you explore
these materials can be used to craft
many items that will help you on your
journey including healing items lures
smoke bombs a mysterious invention
called a pokeball and more
your pokemon team can help you collect
these materials too
you can find all kinds of useful
resources across the region just by
breaking rocks picking up plants growing
in the wild grass defeating or catching
pokemon or knocking items out of trees
[Music]
here we see the trainer using some of
the materials they have collected to
craft items in preparation for their
next mission
[Music]
all kinds of pokemon will appear
depending on the time of the day and the
weather condition different species of
pokemon also have different temperaments
some may ignore you as you approach like
this badoo
some species like starly are skittish
and will run away if they see you
approaching
there are even aggressive pokemon that
will attack you should they spot you in
the wild
if an aggressive pokemon spots you or if
you fail to catch it on your first sneak
attempt the pokemon will enter an alert
state
in this state all pokeballs you throw
will simply be deflected by the pokemon
in order to catch a pokemon in this
state you must battle it
you can initiate a battle by throwing a
pokeball containing one of your own
partner pokemon near a wild pokemon
oh
[Music]
you can use items to your advantage when
catching wild pokemon
for example throwing a berry near a
pokemon will distract it the pokemon
will then start eating while eating the
pokemon is much less aware of your
presence allowing you to go in for a
backstroke
[Music]
when encountering aggressive wild
pokemon you have to be careful
these pokemon will not think twice about
attacking you
if you take too much damage you will
black out and lose some of the items you
are carrying when you fainted
as part of the survey core
you are on a mission to catalog and
research all the different pokemon that
live in the harsh environments of hisui
not only will you need to catch many
types of pokemon on your mission but you
will also need to observe them using
certain moves or displaying certain
behaviors when you are finished in the
field you can visit professor lavinton
to hand in your survey report
this will update your pokedex as well as
increase your rank in the survey core
you will also receive funds from the
professor which you can use to buy items
and materials to help you with your
research
the vastness of the hisoui region is
daunting to explore on foot
luckily throughout your adventure you
will encounter a number of special
pokemon that will help you get to where
you need to go with grace and speed
weirdier helps you navigate on land
faster
isuian braviary on the other hand allows
you to soar through the skies
[Music]
basket legion allows you to traverse the
rivers and seas throughout the hisi
region with these pokemon by your side
you will be able to explore the hisui
region to your heart's content
jubalife village is the center of
operations for the galaxy expedition
team a group made up of people who have
come from different regions to study and
live in the harsh region of hisu
the galaxy team includes various core
such as the medical corps and the
security corps as well as the survey
corps which carries out research on how
pokemon live jubilife village will serve
as the base for your surveying missions
after receiving a mission or a request
and preparing for your next excursion
you'll set out from the village to study
one of the various areas of the hisou
region after you finish your survey work
you'll return once more to prepare for
your next task
along with the headquarters of the
galaxy team and your own lodgings
jubalife village is also home to a
variety of different services such as
the clothier
the craftworks and the trading post
where you can trade pokemon with other
players
you can receive a variety of different
missions and requests from the
inhabitants of hisu
requests are small tasks that you do to
help the residents of hisui while
missions will advance the main story
once you receive a mission or request it
will be added to your arc phone
the arc phone is a mysterious device
that allows you to track your movements
mark locations on the map and track your
current missions and requests
missions and requests vary in their
objectives
some examples of these objectives
include discovering a specific pokemon
finding a variety of different items
defeating powerful pokemon in battle
or catching a number of one specific
pokemon for research
please enjoy this clip of a trainer
completing a request
oh
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can initiate a pokemon battle by
throwing one of your partner's pokeballs
at or near a wild pokemon if a wild
pokemon does not see you approaching and
you strike them with one of your
partner's pokeballs this will catch them
unaware and may grant you an extra
chance to attack in battle
[Music]
battles are turn-based and you can get
your pokemon to attack in two unique
styles
strong style
or agile style
[Music]
using a move in the agile style raises
the user's action speed which may make
the user's next term come sooner at the
expense of reducing the moves power
strong style moves can allow you to
attack with more power but using them
may delay your pokemon's next turn if an
enemy can withstand one of your strong
style moves
prepare to be attacked multiple times in
retaliation using agile style moves and
strong style moves in battle causes your
pokemon's attacks to use more pp
so be careful when planning your battles
a good strategy is the key to victory
while surveying the wild you may come
across a pokemon that appears different
to the others of the same species these
are known as alpha pokemon and are much
larger and have glowing red eyes be
careful when approaching them if you are
not prepared they are very aggressive
and will take a powerful team and
strategy to take down
here the player uses agile style thunder
wave to paralyze their opponent delaying
their turns and making them easier to
catch
while also changing move priority in an
advantageous way for the player
strategies like this are key to
defeating alpha pokemon
catching an alpha pokemon is a challenge
but if you manage it they will be a very
powerful ally on your adventure
by visiting the clothier you can
customize your character with a variety
of different clothing items
as you progress through the game you
will unlock more outfits to purchase
make sure to pick a style that speaks to
you
here is a quick look at some of the
early customization options that
trainers can wear
[Music]
you can also customize your trainer's
hairstyle hair color and eyebrow color
at the hairdresser
[Music]
the hisui region can be dangerous but
that doesn't mean you can't look your
best
[Music]
during your adventure you will have to
face off against special pokemon called
noble pokemon
a strange phenomenon is causing the
nobles to become frenzied making them
rampage
as part of the survey corps you will be
recruited to calm these frenzied nobles
simply defeating them in battle will not
calm them you will have to quell their
frenzy by throwing bombs made using
these noble pokemon's favorite foods it
can be difficult to hit a rampaging
noble with these bombs as they will
relentlessly attack you
the moment you see an opportunity hit
them with as many bombs as you can
just like throwing the pokeball you need
to aim carefully noble pokemon will
attack the player directly and if you
take too much damage you will black out
and need to attempt the battle again
balance throwing your bombs with dodging
attacks the calm the noble pokemon
at some point during the fight the noble
pokemon may let down its guard this is
the time to throw your pokeball and
start a pokemon battle
these battles are tough and planning
ahead is essential if you wish to calm
the noble pokemon down
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed this sneak peek of
pokemon legends arceus
countless adventures await you in the
his region and we cannot wait for you to
get your hands on the game after it
releases on january 28th exclusively on
nintendo switch
we will see you very soon in hisui bye
you